[Música]
descartamos sombras dolia
mis queridos amigos y amigas de
visualpolitik este viejo proverbio ruso
que tiene sus versiones en prácticamente
todos los idiomas viene a decir que
cuando el gato no está los ratones
bailan como todo el mundo sabe el gato
Putin está demasiado ocupado con Ucrania
así que por si no tuviéramos bastantes
Guerras en este 2022 ha resucitado de
nuevo el viejo conflicto de nagorno
karabajo azerbaiyán lanza ataques de
Gran alcance contra Armenia básicamente
como el kremlin no está actualmente en
condiciones de mediar entre ambos como
siempre había hecho antes azerbaiyán ha
vuelto a la carga con la novedad de que
esta vez ha atacado directamente
territorio armenio Y esto es un problema
para Europa Y diréis por qué azerbaiyán
suministra gas a la Unión Europea no
solo eso es una sólida alternativa alga
ruso en el momento en el que hacemos
este vídeo Armenia y azerbaiyán ya han
negociado otro alto el fuego que solo
Dios sabe lo que durará pero una cosa
está Clara Rusia ya no tiene la
influencia que tenía en esta zona
sí amigos de visualpolitik la Guerra de
Ucrania lo está cambiando todo y donde
hay una crisis hay una oportunidad no
solo a nivel energético sino también
político porque estamos ante la
oportunidad de que la Unión Europea
pueda tener influenciar y no la tengan
otras potencias y mucho ojo porque
cuando hablamos de otras potencias no
estamos hablando de Rusia precisamente
atentos el presidente chino sillín Busca
abrir puertas en Asia central mientras
la guerra en Ucrania deja deteriorada a
Rusia la cuestión es que Europa está
empezando a dar pasos hacia Asia central
pero como os podéis imaginar negociar
con este tipo de dictaduras no da buena
imagen y solo es una fuente de problemas
nunca será plato de buen gusto decir que
entre los mejores amigos de Bruselas
están los aliyev o el nuevo dictador de
turkmenistán el hijo de arcadas que es
un viejo conocido a quien visualpolitik
los que nos seguís desde hace unos
cuantos años ya sabéis unas cuantas
historias de este auténtico pirado que
hizo erigir estatuas de oro a él mismo y
a su perro favorito Pues bien su hijo
que le está sucediendo no parece ser
mucho mejor quizás por Europa sea mejor
depender de varios demonios que de uno
solo pero visto el panorama no significa
que vaya a ser sencillo salir del
infierno Así que la pregunta es Qué
problema supone para la Unión Europea
que azerbaiyán ataque de un nuevo
Armenia Cómo puede Bruselas meter a ese
central en su zona de influencia de
verdad puede tener gas barato y a la vez
meterle un gol a Rusia y a China hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes sabéis Cómo podéis apoyar aviso al
politic de forma activa pues entrando en
nuestra comunidad de patreon no solo
estaréis contribuyendo a que
visualpolitik siga adelante además
tendréis acceso a merchandising
exclusivo como esta camiseta que lleva
puesta que no está a la venta y lo
estará nunca la única forma de
conseguirla es formando parte de nuestra
comunidad en patreon pero no solo eso
además tenemos una newsletter semanal
las claves de la semana donde tratamos
temas que no nos da tiempo a cubrir en
forma de vídeos así que ya sabéis os
espero a todo el mundo en la comunidad
de visualpolitik en patreon y ahora sí
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
nuestra historia de hoy comienza muy
lejos de turkmenistán concretamente a
4.500 km Vamos a viajar a un lugar del
océano Índico del que ya os hemos
hablado un montón aquí en visualpolitik
me estoy refiriendo exactamente a las
islas de andamán y nicobar un
archipiélago perteneciente a la India
que es el gran talón de Aquiles de China
la economía china devora recursos sin
cesar esto en cierta forma convierte a
China en un gigante con pies de barro
porque buena parte de su suministros de
petróleo y de otras materias primas
pasan por el Estrecho de malaca Así que
si en algún momento las cosas se
pusieran feas con china sus rivales
podrían aprovechar las islas de andamán
y nicobar para bloquear la navegación
por el Índico y dejarle sin recursos
aquí es donde para china empieza a
cobrar relevancia Asia central pensad
que estamos hablando de una región que
hasta hace poco no le importaba a nadie
salvo a Rusia porque sí Asia central la
tierra de los instantes tiene muchos
recursos naturales pero escasa capacidad
para explotarlos un buen ejemplo de esto
es turkmenistán al ritmo de producción
actual Rusia tiene reservas de gas para
58 años y Qatar para 144 Pues bien
turkmenistán tiene gas para los próximos
230 años esto quiere decir dos cosas Una
que tienen muchísimo gas y dos que no lo
están sacando partido
[Música]
se necesita muchísima inversión para
poner en marcha un campo de producción
de gas y más aún para instalar la
infraestructura necesaria para
exportarlo pero claro allí donde hay
hidrocarburos china siempre ha estado
dispuesta a poner todos los yuanes que
hicieran falta para que esto fuera
realidad atentos a este mapa el
gasoducto china Asia central que
atraviesa Uzbekistán y kazajistán
permite a China desde el año 2010
obtener gas de turkmenistán antes este
país le vendía Rusia la mayor parte de
su gas pero las cosas han cambiado y
mucho en los últimos años tanto que ya
en 2021 le exportó a Beijing 31 bcm es
decir 31 mil millones de metros cúbicos
de gas el triple Respecto a los 10 bcms
que le vendió a Moscú
turkmenistán es el principal
suministrador de gasa China por
gasoducto y el segundo en total si
tenemos en cuenta el gas natural licuado
de Australia de hecho la capacidad del
gasoducto china Asia central de unos
55.000 millones de metros cúbicos
anuales no tienen hoy por hoy
competencia a la hora de suministrar gas
a China por tierra por ejemplo el
gasoducto el poder de Siberia que
conecta china con Rusia espera alcanzar
los 38.000 millones de metros cúbicos en
2025 un 30% menos por todo esto subraya
la importancia que turkmenistán tiene
para China
todos nos hemos enterado de la última
reunión de singping con Putin en
samarkanda pero de lo que no se ha
hablado tanto es de que el presidente
chino también se reunió con Los líderes
de los cinco países de Asia central este
interés de Beijing en la región se
traduce en que a medida que crece la
influencia China disminuye la rusa y hay
tres motivos por los que esta tendencia
irá más el primero es que china es un
socio comercial mucho más atractivo que
Rusia en segundo lugar nadie quiere
apostar por el caballo perdedor y hombre
pues la de Ucrania no pinta muy bien
para Putin Y por último no hay que
olvidar que kazajistán es el país
referencia de la región y como ya hemos
visto en anteriores vídeos de
visualpolitik kazajistán está marcando
cada vez más distancias con el kremlich
[Música]
de hecho en las semanas previas a cuando
hacíamos Este vídeo ha vuelto a hacerlo
esta vez con un artículo firmado por el
propio presidente toca Jeff en
político.eu que como sabéis es el medio
estrella de los políticos de Bruselas
atentos
de kazajistán avanzamos a toda velocidad
hacia la reforma que china gana
influencia en Asia Central es un
programa para Europa pero también para
los Estados Unidos fundamentalmente
porque a medida que Beijing se hace con
los recursos naturales de estos cinco
países los hispanes disminuye la
importancia de un posible bloqueo a los
suministros con dirección a China y
claro desde un punto de vista
geopolítico occidente quiere que el
estatus quo sigue igual porque le
interesa mantener la carta de disuasión
en el Índico en este caso disuasión
geopolítica
[Música]
pero es que además también está la
posibilidad de que turkmenistán venda su
gas natural a Europa lo cual le vendría
de perlas para reducir la dependencia de
Rusia ahora mismo la comisión europea
está buscando la fórmula para reemplazar
esos 150 bcms que se compraban a Rusia
todos los años el objetivo es
diversificar los suministros Pues bien
con Estados Unidos ya se ha cerrado un
acuerdo para hacerse con el gas natural
licuado así lo explicó la presidenta
Úrsula wonderlayen atentos
[Música]
El problema es que el gnl es más caro
que el que llega por gasoducto tener
energía barata era hasta ahora una de
las principales bazas de competitividad
de Europa frente a Asia Así que Europa
necesita gas procedente de diferentes
sitios sí pero a ser posible También
necesita gas barato por tanto la mejor
opción de los 27 para complementar el
gnl de países como Estados Unidos o
Qatar pasa por las tuberías que sean
capaces de traer más gas que el cáucaso
y de Asia central y justo Aquí está el
kit de la cuestión
vamos a ver ahora qué es lo que se está
haciendo atentos
yo pongo el caviar tú pones las latas
azerbaiyán llevan medio siglo gobernado
por la misma familia los en casa
gobiernan con puño de hierro pero con
los de fuera se esfuerzan y mucho por
agradar sobre todo si son políticos
europeos tu problema es que hacer tratos
con dictaduras nunca Es agradable Así
que desde bakú la capital azar y
pusieron en marcha algo que los
seguidores más veteranos de
visualpolitik ya conocéis la diplomacia
del caviar porque claro es más fácil
hacer amigos con caviar y bueno alguna
que otra señorita de buen perro y ojo
porque estaba muy en serio en azerbaiyán
no se han cortado un pelo a la hora de
comprar a los políticos europeos de
hecho desde Bruselas llegaron a dar
instrucciones a los diplomáticos y
eurodiputados de que estuvieran alerta
que si una chica guapa se te acercaba y
te decía algo parecido a Quiero saber
cómo de largo es tu gasoducto no no te
vayas con ella cuidado que no quieres
ser tu amiga no te vayas con ella
querido los diputado porque te quiere
chantajear para que defiendas a hacer
vayán y diréis Pero qué intereses tiene
en Europa Pues atentos a este mapa
[Música]
como os podéis imaginar muchas presiones
de Rusia para que este proyecto se
quedara en un cajón porque Rusia llegó a
financiar a partidos políticos como el
movimiento 5 estrellas de Italia para
evitar que se gasoducto se construyera
al final la última parte del corredor
sur del gas el tap es decir el gasoducto
trans adriático empezó a operar en
diciembre de 2020 esto ha permitido que
actualmente azerbaiyán le esté vendiendo
Europa diez veces y ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando muchos hombre pues
Comparado con los 150 bcms que nos
llegan de Rusia Esto no es nada pero lo
importante es que se han vuelto las
tornas por completo porque con la Guerra
de Ucrania resulta que ahora somos los
europeos los que hemos pasado a suplicar
azerbaiyán que nos dé más gas Bruselas
ya cerró un acuerdo con azerbaiyán para
duplicar los envíos de gas para 2027
allí en bakú estuvo wonderlayen que tan
pronto está con vaiden como con Ali jeb
y Esta sí que no necesita que le lleguen
chicas guapas atectos
en Italia se queda sin gas en un par de
meses Porque esa es la auténtica
realidad del corredor sur de gas Trae
poco gas Europa y por mucho que en 2027
va a llegar el doble es el doble de muy
poco ahora bien Vamos a fijarnos en el
tanat el gasoducto trans anatolio
el tanat de 1840 kilómetros recibe el
gas de azerbaiyán en la frontera con
Georgia y cruza toda Turquía hasta la
frontera con Grecia donde arranca el tap
este gasoducto que mayoritariamente es
propiedad de socar la compañía estataly
tiene capacidad para 16 bcms de los
cuales 6 se quedan en Turquía dos en
Grecia y 8 llegan hasta Italia
Pues bien Lo más importante es que este
gasoducto está diseñado como un
gasoducto escalable esto significa que
su capacidad se puede ir ampliando
añadiendo circuitos paralelos y más
potencia con estaciones compresoras esto
significa que con una inversión
contenida de alrededor de 7.000 millones
de dólares pasará a tener una capacidad
de 32 bcms pero esperad un momento
porque hace 10 años los planes de socar
eran transportar 60 bcms lo cual ojo que
ya son palabras mayores y claro la gran
pregunta es Pero por qué hacer vayan no
explota esto
[Música]
en primer lugar porque hacen falta
muchos millones Para desarrollar los
campos de producción de gas para que os
hagáis una idea SAT deniz el
megallacimiento de azerbaiyán ha
significado una inversión de 27.000
millones de dólares para que actualmente
produzca unos escasos 21 bcms al año con
este dinero se pueden construir 70
hospitales a todo trapo y aquí es cuando
azerbaiyán le ha dicho Europa Úrsula yo
pongo el caviar tú pones las latas el
presidente aliex dice que aumentar las
exportaciones de gas requiere
inversiones y garantías vale lleva dicho
que es Europa quiere más gas que vengan
sus petroleras a invertir en el país y
os preguntaréis Pero por qué hacer vayan
que antes chantajeaba políticos europeos
con chicas de buen ver ahora nos da
calabazas Bueno pues porque bakú
desconfía de las intenciones de Europa a
largo plazo primero no hay absolutamente
nada que impida que Europa vuelva a
comprar casa Rusia pueden pasar mil
cosas por ejemplo que Putin entre en
razón y se rinda que nos vuelva a vender
el gas todo es posible en estos momentos
azerbaiyán desconfía de Europa y Europa
desconfía de azerbaiyán no tiene sentido
dejar de depender del malvado Putin para
empezar a depender del Igualmente
malvado al ieb Así que quien nos queda
pues atentos
[Música]
el paraíso del gas
imagináis un país con unas reservas de
gas cinco veces más grandes que la de
azerbaiyán no hace falta imaginarlo ese
país existe y se llama turkmenistán vale
que también es una dictadura de hecho es
una especie de versión estúpida de Corea
del Norte pero tiene una ventaja a sus
dictadores les gusta más gastar el
dinero en estatuas de oro gigantes que
en bombas nucleares literalmente el
nuevo dictador de turkmenistán es este
señor que veis en pantalla os presento a
serdar verdi Mohamed el hijo del
anterior dictador cuyo nombre no voy a
intentar pronunciar de nuevo porque
podría estar invocando al [ __ ] sin
darme cuenta y ya sé lo que diréis
muchos una dictadura hereditaria es que
nunca vamos a dejar de hacer tratos con
esta gente pues Bueno al menos
turkmenistán es una dictadura que no
pretende invadir a nadie ya es algo por
ahí ya podemos estar tranquilos ya que
las fuerzas armadas turmenas han
mostrado esta ferocidad a la hora de
recibir a su nuevo dictador
[Música]
es pegadizo en otras palabras que
turmeristan pues no es precisamente el
terror de Asia central Así que la Unión
Europea debería Buscar un acuerdo
similar al alcanzado por china
básicamente en este caso el gigante
asiático le dijo a tu organistan No te
preocupes por nada yo exploto el
yacimiento y te construyo gasoducto y
luego tú ya me pagas con los servicios
prestados por gas pero habéis visto cómo
bailan si es que estaré encantados y
muchos estaréis pensando pero bueno Y
por qué Europa no se le ocurrió antes
algo así fundamentalmente porque sería
necesario construir el gasoducto
transcaspiano
que este proyecto ha estado bloqueado
durante décadas porque tenían que dar su
visto bueno todos los países ribereños
del mar caspio lo que incluye Rusia e
Irán sin embargo mi querida comunidad de
visualpolitik la Situación ha cambiado
desde 2018 cuando se firmó el acuerdo
internacional sobre el estatus legal del
mar caspio ahora bastaría con un acuerdo
solo entre azerbaiyán y turkmenistán
para construir el gasoducto algo
Bastante factible después de que ambos
países sean resueltos su eterna disputa
por el yacimiento de gas
turkmenistán y azerbaiyán desarrollarán
conjuntamente el campo dosluc en el
caspio en cualquier caso pueden pasar
varios años hasta que se construya el
dichoso gaseoducto transcarpiano Y eso
si llega a hacerse así que ya se barajan
tres alternativas para que el gas de
turkmenistán llegue azerbaiyán camino de
la Unión Europea una fórmula es hacerlo
llegar a territorio mediante barcos
convertidos en gas natural comprimido
otra opción es la que propone la empresa
estadounidense trans caspian resorts un
interconector de 48 millas para que el
gasto menos transite entre un yacimiento
de turnistan y otro de que están en
aguas del caspio y la tercera fórmula ya
está funcionando y mucho ojo porque aquí
interviene un actor de lo más inesperado
turkmenistán inicia suministro de gas de
intercambio a azerbaiyán a través de
Irán habéis oído bien según este acuerdo
tres bandas turkmenistán suministrará
actualmente cuatro bcm a Irán en su
frontera noroeste y las regiones del
noroeste de la república islámica que
producen gas suministrarán cada año
cuatro bcms azerbaiyán
como podéis ver que Europa consigue el
gas de turkmenistán no va a resultar
nada sencillo tampoco es que sea la
panacea pero sí es la mejor manera de
atraer Asia central a la Esfera de
influencia Europea y evitar dejar el
terreno libre a China en la región
supondría además anotarse un tanto en el
ámbito de la seguridad y el económico al
conseguir un suministro de gas estable y
barato y es la oportunidad de ser el
nuevo gato en la región pero ahora las
preguntas son para vosotros creéis que
Europa debería apostar por el gasoducto
trascaspiano o creéis que ya está bien
de lidiar con dictaduras y que la
auténtica alternativa al gas ruso es
nuclear más renovables podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios
Mientras tanto no olvidéis que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos a
este canal para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]